Patriot male today we are going to dig
into Patriot mail a fine Rand and Ronald
Reagan had a baby and suckled that child
off the teat of Liberty its cries would
sound a little something like Patriot
Man right written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America freedom
mixed signals this week in hatred mail
let's take a listen together and see if
we can make some sense out of it
what a [ __ ] pajama boy Pakman TYT and
Pakman are unhinged also Infowars have
more credibility than the corporate
media and even more credible than this
garbage channel Pakman smear job fail
you know how David Pakman can make
murica great again drop another
shirtless photo on Instagram come on
David Pakman you can make murica great
again what percent of your subscribers
actually exist I can't tell if they hate
me or if they're enamored with me
because they're both saying that
everything I do is terrible yet I could
make America great again by putting
another shirtless picture of myself up
on Instagram I mean they could hate you
but also be attracted to you it's also
interesting because maybe maybe the
first put photo you put up made America
good again but not so far as to make it
great again yeah it's a blurry
distinction between the two and also
what we have to do with TYT why are
people writing to me about TYT I don't
know why and then you know the fake
subscribers allegation no how many of
your subscribers are actually real come
on it's weak stuff you can turn hatred
mail into something positive if you use
the coupon code hey tree at 40 at david
pakman.com slash membership it will give
you a huge Bigley tremendous discount
off of membership patriot 40 is the code